we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
hey
folks here we are we might be drunk
we're doing it it's the new year
yeah yeah 2022
baby here we are some of us are going
away so uh backlogging a little yeah
yeah you got that right you've been good
i've been good i did a whole southern
run and uh just over the weekend i went
to atlanta i think rented a car drove to
charlotte
it's gonna be back oh man how was
charlotte i was there the week before
you great club but just like you we we
had a killer crowds like those crowds
are like i could do a special here yeah
and then the saturday late show was like
[ __ ] bachelorette drunk lady got
thrown out for standing up and yelling
yeah uh the let's go brandon [ __ ]
started going i mean it was uh it was
babysitting yeah we some of these
crowds are like don't be so the south
for a second you do get that [ __ ] where
you get like uh
and look i get it like you see some [ __ ]
it's like coming in new york and you see
a homeless guy like take a [ __ ] right in
front of you and you're like all right
like you're rubbing it in yes you know
what i mean
that's what happened there was a there
was a crowd of uh
this happened to me in springfield
missouri there was a woman who she's
heckling me [ __ ] face at one point she
goes you're not bad looking for a jew
and i was like wow i mean this is you
guys are just going in huh
that's kind of a compliment it is a
compliment but it's also not yes of
course
i had the ladies talking on the right
and i go late i mean come on and they
wanna they all went like this
i'm like i'm the bad guy you guys are
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're killing me here
you're coming here you're all dressed up
they got like eight bottles of champagne
on the table i'm like get out of here
you're gonna die alone
that is that is a good one the dialogue
we were talking about that [ __ ] with
derosa uh last weekend yeah it's so true
that you just go to you're gonna die
alone maybe two weeks ago because that's
i had like this woman in miami it's like
the to the clubs in the club's defense
they don't quite know because i'm
getting enough laughs for a while that
they're like oh he's working off this
but then there's a there's a point where
it just turns yes like this woman i'm
drinking a glass of wine on stage the
club was very nice they got me the
natural wine in the green room i'm like
hey gary veeder and i he hates it but
i'm drinking it yeah and i'm like it's
kind of fun to get a little wine buzzed
on uh in miami sure you go out there
this woman keeps heckling and she goes i
like boxed wine you know i
like all right what a thing to brag
about
i'm like all right you're trash whatever
and uh i'm like what do you brag about
riding the bus you know it's like
she's just like she's like i like boxing
i'm like sure it's i mean doesn't it
hurt you it's going on and on for a long
time and then finally gets to a point
where i'm like all right lady we get
like we get it and i i kind of gotten
you know when you get that one applause
and you're like well this should be over
this is peaked it's not getting any
better and then she comes back but box
wine's better and i'm like
oh my god this chick this is your big uh
stamp on on the world is box wine
she's in a blackout and she's not gonna
remember and all she's gonna remember
the next day is like i was funny yeah
exactly i talked to the comedian it was
really funny and she'll talk to one
self-aware friend like you're a [ __ ]
idiot yeah hopefully probably not they
probably don't have that stole the show
you were great the whole box wine thing
you gotta you gotta do a show about that
that's hilarious how you just say you
like a thing yeah that's the show box
wine is such i like handicap hookers
what are you talking about
that's not a point of pride box wine
yeah it's terrible speaking of booze
though oh yeah we got a we got a special
guest bartender here
as jamie the bear jew transitioned
a half jew yeah half do you have cuban
puerto rican puerto rican oh i was just
in miami i assume everyone's cuban right
now
is a great punk band
half jupiter jew and puerto rican is
like as new york as it gets to me right
where else would those two people meet
that's perfect good point in new york i
love it it's a west side story yeah i'm
the result of that having a happy ending
yeah
i heard the new movie is great i heard
it's good i saw yesterday it's good
crying and singing for what oh i'm
excited but i don't think it's that long
ah it was really really three hours no
it's a little over two but it's really
good
two hour plus for a musical movies a lot
i know what the the lyrics are so good
it's really worth it it is baby i
usually hate
yeah me too but this was killer i felt
like it was a sleeper i feel like i i've
been hearing a lot about this and that i
don't i didn't feel like i heard too
much buzz about this
they probably didn't need to it's
spielberg they're like people are gonna
see it it's spielberg true you you know
what i like when movies do this they
just they're advertising just west side
story you don't see spielberg you know
the actors are like the name is enough i
love that that's kind of cool relatively
unknown cast except for tony i think
who's tony the baby driver guy angel
because we're related oh you are yeah
he's on uh yeah he's on the other side
he's a good guy he didn't know he was in
that movie of course i knew he's in it
no i see i've seen the ads no good for
him he's not bad looking for a gentile
imagine being a spielberg's pr person
just sit back i know what a gig yeah
he's just in peru right now he's doing
ayahuasca he's just on vacation he
doesn't care he's just on epstein's
island kicking back living life
he's like don't promote this either
all right so what do you what do you got
cooking for us there james of course a
traditional uh puerto rican drink that
we have over the holidays and it's good
all year round but um you probably
already did eggnog right we did i
actually thought that i i saw you
outside the cellar i thought you
mentioned that you wanted to make an
eggnog i didn't know what you're making
but i was expecting eggnog it's not
eggnog but it is they call it puerto
rican eggnog it's called coquito oh
it doesn't know it's dead coconut in
spanish i see so normally not how you
want your penis described
i brought like what's in it because i
wanted to explain why it's different
from eggnog so eggnog is really eggs
milk and sugar and then you put in like
the booze and cinnamon and everything so
it's basically like the ingredients of a
cake without flour right so this is
coconut-based so we have coconut milk
you have to have coconut milk creme de
coco and sweetened condensed milk
and rum
and then you can kind of like experiment
with eggnog is also can be whiskey as
well right so you can do bourbon or
rum or whiskey whatever i think in the
like when it was created it was
originally had with whiskey yeah that's
how i do it back from the 13th century
like britain it's like really wow wow
cause puerto rican um there's a lot of
salmonella going around in those days
we haven't cracked this yet right and
then the americans came and put booze in
it i think they just had it without for
a while just like a warm grog
english just had it but it helps you
sleep it's like one of those like before
bed drinks yeah so then they boozed it
up and then there was some riot in like
the 1800s called like the eggnog riots
really yeah wow like kind of like the
first sanicon it was just a bunch of
americans
getting wasted around christmas time on
eggnog and i think that's why it became
a christmas time treat wow i didn't know
that look at that fun fact riot that's
been around a long time but um coquito's
only been around since like the night
it's only a 1900s thing okay and uh so
yeah so what i have here best names in
puerto rico mafumbo and coquita fungo
mafungo sorry
okay it's not a great fish
no it's not a fish but um so what's in
this is actually the mix and then the
rum is here and i'm gonna mix these two
together because it's actually a lot of
work all right
this but i'll explain what's in it like
i said you have the creme de coco the
sweetened condensed milk coconut canned
food drive right here where's the goya
what is it thanksgiving i did not want
to bring the [ __ ] i did coco lopez okay
all right all right promoting
my drug dealer
so all that's in it plus some vanilla
and then cinnamon nutmeg and you can
experiment with how you want to make it
otherwise there's i went to a coquito
competition damn
um bacardi through and i tried like 10
different coquitos under 10 minutes
because i was late and i wanted to make
a fair judgment of which one i thought
was best so i got hammered and felt very
full i appreciate it i mixed these two
now because i already kind of
pre-batched this at home oh boy so yeah
let me shake it up because it gets it
gets thick yeah you know how these
drinks go the day of a tell joke eggnog
or as i call it elf com
slap it down your own back yeah oh look
at that he's a comedy comedy
oh yeah david tells the king like
i floated him doing this and he said he
said it will come on the new year
i'm gonna see him at caroline's he
always does the uh the holidays at
caroline that's right there's no one
better yeah i mean there's no better
holiday thing to do i mean uh so we are
pre-recording this because of uh a lot
of us going away but
uh yeah the attel
carol that's i saw him do that when i
was in high school wow so that's how
long dave has been doing that i have
this is gonna sound so [ __ ] cheesy
i have an autographed playbill of his
from like 2004. i love it yeah i wasn't
a comic yet wow you still have it i i
think it says thanks davidtail ah i love
it david tell a great line uh doug
stanhope was doing caroline's and david
tell walks in because he's a fan and
stan hope from the stage goes what are
you doing here dave and he goes i was
walking down broadway i heard a white
voice coming out of caroline's i had to
see what it was
they booked a lot of urban acts
but yeah he's the king the king man
oh i'm excited for this
oh boy i mean you can always add more
too
yeah oh look at that look at the garnish
this is i'm not a pro bartender but you
know i know a couple things yeah henry
hill said they used to shave a guy's
head and use it on his head one of those
cheese graters what to torture him wow
i need that for my dandruff
with a cinnamon stick oh my god
this one looks good
oh wow oh man
hey hey cheers call this a baby batter
on the rocks
they're not allowed in texas
dude
that is stupid good
welcome oh my god
sally you should really be having one of
these one just a tiny shot yeah just
just just on the lip
[Laughter]
hit the glasses
just on my glasses
this is a very mature podcast yeah um
that's delightful oh it is good dude i
went to a cuban restaurant in um miami
called uh versailles have you heard of
this i've heard of this oh my god
somebody told me to go there i'm with
vitor so he just orders like eight
things of me he's such a jew on the road
he's like we got to try everything
[Laughter]
thank you so much thank jamo this is
delightful this is
insanely good puerto rican eggnog oh i
have two of these i don't know my kids
coconut milk this seems like underrated
in a cocktail i agreed
damn this tastes like the holidays right
here puerto ricans and thailand love
coconut
everything on thai is coconut coconut
milk coconut curry
yeah you're right
[Music]
the the thai yeah they oh man all those
curries man my coconut shrimp what what
color you red or green or you go
massaman whatever i'm red all day yeah i
like it spicy yeah
um i gotta give can i give you a peeve
oh jeez where are you
guys started here is it too soon for a
pee yeah we're talking about
i wanted to hear a little bit about that
a peeve is like a drink okay well it's
related to miami so
i'll work my way up yeah versailles
first off look up their cuban sandwich
it's insane
i was i got to be honest i was kind of
looking for something more traditional
but veda pushed me hard on the cuban
and i wanted something like ropa vieja
one of the you know beef things but yeah
look at that look at that damn
it's like a panini with edge
i love a
i love a good panini man but look at
that you get the
cubans never been like my go-to sandwich
but when you get one done right
it's great because you get a cheap cube
and it's kind of crap but you get a [ __ ]
you get a good one like the right pork
and yeah the mustard and the pickle and
the cheese you're like that's a [ __ ]
killer and for some reason you don't
feel as weighed down as if you just had
barbecue or something that's true
yeah how often are you getting pork on a
sandwich i guess you have a ham sandwich
pork roll
pork roll it's like a jersey thing right
i don't know pork pork roll sounds like
a blues musician
old pork roll
he played the sacks
yeah let's see oh yeah there's a cuban
place in soho that everybody loves
what's it
called god i can't think of it's always
got a line out the door it's a little
hipstery
look at that it's a cuban joint
in in soho always got a line around it
they do a big brunch too oh i can't
think of it very popular
give it a goog what is this this is the
pork roll oh okay
that's like a muffin
i guess for some reason pork is okay on
breakfast sandwiches but we don't do it
as much it's more of a supporting player
like
it's the uh turkey club the bacon the
bacon's there but it's in a william h
macy type type role it's not strong
supporting it's song supporting right
but we're not getting you're not not all
the leads but then you got pulled pork
which is all pork pulled pork is good
but again if you get it done wrong yep
that's that's just one ticket to
diarrhea city
it's terrible i mean
[Music]
[Laughter]
any money is it cafe habana
that's it that's it should have put that
together
this is insane delightful and you drink
too many of these though you're gonna
[ __ ] out uh you know pillsbury doughboy
yeah i mean speaking of diarrhea city
yeah i'm gonna have to have a second one
of these they're really they're really
good oh yeah source what do you think
peters you want one
oh [ __ ] we gotta yeah we gotta get one
for uh for our producer matt peters
the man behind the scenes it's a huge
hit what now what are you pouring in
there so this is the mix that i made
with the oh you made that yeah oh and
put it in the part i said the thing that
puerto ricans do is once they make
cookie do they just put it back in the
rum bottle and gift it to you
so you'll just see a lot of like bacardi
filled coquito bottles i like it yeah
nice
and there was bacardi spiced and gold
mixed into this but you can use whatever
puerto rican rum you want it doesn't
have to be those but i just like the
flavor of bacardi spice now i gotta ask
you're puerto rican and jewish what do
you feel closer to right it depends like
today i've got the hoops and the hair
slicked back right drinking coquitos so
puerto rico but you're hanging out with
me yeah exactly so there's that ten
percent that's like
i got that same like
yes
i like that that's just become a
stereotype about jews like we're just
annoyed or annoying yeah
those are like the stereotypes now we're
up like in a big jewish neighborhood
lower east side right behind cos bialys
and the pickle guys and yeah so yeah i
felt very jewish even your your
neighborhood was puerto rican jewish
like you're exactly your environment
which of your parents is puerto rican
your dad's puerto rican your mom is
jewish
so my mom's like just angry and i'm in
therapy
[Laughter]
a one-man show
i'm sure though back then
uh a puerto rican was pretty exotic not
exotic but like it's a sexy swarthy
latino for uh for a
disgusting nebushi jewish woman oh yeah
she was on a mission
jesus [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
i was talking about mark's talking about
jews like we're on animal planet or
something what the hell
she picked him up at the gym so she was
she was poaching oh okay she said it was
between him and a jamaican guy wow damn
yeah she was after it you know wow
[ __ ] that's a horny jewish she worked
out i don't think she ever went
puerto rican or jamaican right right
jamaican
bacon yeah
is it is that a big thing jews and
jamaicans that's gonna be at least one
there's gotta be one i don't think it's
like a huge
[Music]
sure but most reggae is too chill jews
we're too whiny you know right like
you're thinking like bob marley i was
just like my buffalo soldier we'd just
be like what's with this soldier here's
what's going on here i mean that's
that's true going on here uh
a lot of weed don't you think
it's a little too much weird i don't i
really do turn into like my most jewish
self when i uh smoke weed because the
voices just pop in where they're like
who do you think you are it's like your
mother where you're like shame on you
right you're this high you think you're
gonna go anywhere in your career when
you're this high i'm like oh
it's funny because i turn jewish when i
smoke weed too really get your act
together what are you doing you suck you
gotta start reading more
yeah well weed i think it's like taps
into your worst uh insecurities for some
people some people it works oh yeah i'm
not one of those people i wish i was
these guys would wake and bake and all
that [ __ ] i'm like do you wish you were
that person though well that's a good
point but they smoke and they're like ah
it's almost like medicine for them and
i'm like man that must be nice because
it looks good
this sounds horrible mark's like i would
like to doesn't that sound horrible they
wake up they need like oh thank god i'm
high like that sounds like a [ __ ]
nightmare that's a good point but you
ever read adderall you ever ever ever
had an adderall yeah yeah well like some
i have an adderall i'm like whoa [ __ ]
i'm i'm bouncing off the walls i'm
cleaning the vacuum cleaner and been
putting together a transmission but
other people take an adderall they're
like all right and i think it's the same
with weed yeah i think i'm one of those
people yeah i think i'm one of those
adorable people i tape when i'm like now
i can focus really yeah oh i'm you know
i'm vacuuming the roof really well yeah
i'm just like
road runner sonic the hedgehog crazy
[ __ ]
son whatever happened to sega sega had a
[ __ ] run they had a round remember
sonic and all that [ __ ] they don't have
a system anymore i don't think that was
my thing i wasn't at mario i was always
playing sonic interesting tales was such
a cop my older brother would be like you
can be tails like oh fun
i get to i get to chase you yeah i get
to be robin
thanks
robin at least was there
tails tails you could get off screen i'm
like where is he and he's like we left
him behind yeah that was also when i
knew jim carrey was kind of done when he
was in the sonic the hedgehog movie
i was like oh jim
you were so high up you know what i
think heard him is when he did uh i mean
look he's a legend not much sure jim
carrey but like when he did kick ass too
and then he like came out against guns
and it's like you're in a gun movie dude
no one's saying no one no one's just
assuming you're pro gun right right i
never put that together case in point
alec baldwin but uh
but you know it's like what is i look
there's such a thing as entertainment
like there are [ __ ] movies on the
holocaust i don't think you i don't
think christoph waltz hates jews
right
right we can separate it yeah
that's been a cathartic role though
[Laughter]
what if he puts on the outfit he's like
finally i was born for this
like his adderall yeah exactly even seen
benedict cumberbatch in 12 years a slave
you're like yeah you seem too nice to be
this slave right even even in the movie
he's crying you're like all right this
is you're like you're like the weak
slave owner i would never make one of
those movies if i was because hollywood
is kind of woke now everybody's like
minding their p's and q's so i would
never be in a slave movie because now
you just have footage of you whipping a
black guy saying the n-word i'm like you
could clip that up yeah but roy wood jr
has a bit about how he likes those guys
brilliant because because they're
helping tell the story
so you get guys like leonardo dicaprio
you know who's by the way great in
django oh he's unbelievable unbelievable
as candy good to see him in like against
type too yes
sometimes you get a little typecast at a
certain point yeah when you're just
always the leading man yeah roy's bit is
so good he's like everybody's like tom
cruise does his own stunts he's like
[ __ ] this guy said the n-word
next to samuel l jackson
that's so good i mean
you replay that tarantino sam jackson
scene and you're like
this is all fine and good except for the
fact that he wrote it
that's when it becomes a little like
when an actor like i'm just doing a part
i'm trying to pay my bills tarantino's
like i did the screenplay yeah
yeah dad edward story yeah we were like
all right this is this is
i mean you rewatch that scene you're
like oh boy yeah that was a weird choice
it's a weird show we're choice to take
that role yeah
it's like you could have any role in the
movie right you're like nah this is the
one i want yeah you sure you don't want
to be vince finger
i want the guy in the bathrobe who's
scared of his wife
but his wife was black in the movie
which maybe helps him in some way i'm
sure he did that to [ __ ] with the
audience a little ah bonnie i i mean the
whole coffee thing in that movie like
this good [ __ ] it goes oh yeah i know
it's good i buy it myself that whole
thing
i mean look it's a funny character it's
a great character yeah i love that line
uh that movie is so funny there's so
many like good fellas is hilarious but
uh pulp fiction when he goes uh
hey you gotta wash your hands he goes
[ __ ] you watched me wash him
he's like yeah but when i was done the
rag didn't look like a [ __ ]
taxi maxi pad
i couldn't get it dude samuel jackson
that movie oh he stole it he stole it i
mean travolta is amazing too but like
sam jackson that's like his i mean he's
great in so many movies but like we
gotta
appreciate sam jackson's greatness
because he elevates every [ __ ] movie
he's in he really does and that that
just put him he was always great but
that put him on the map i mean a bad
[ __ ] wallet a honey bunny be
cool ringo i mean it's so good ezekiel
25 17. so okay so we had to do a public
speaking thing in high school and i
remember i was like i'm doing sam
jackson
and i did ezekiel 25 17 and then my
friend went on and did it right after me
but he put on an afro ah and everyone
was like well that was way better
what the [ __ ] he stole your whole thing
he stole my whole thing
i hate that [ __ ] yeah what are you gonna
do he was better he had the afro
yeah i dressed as hulk hogan one year
for halloween and my friend's like well
i'll do it too i'm like what no
you you have a better costume kind of
yeah
like go be owen heart and kill yourself
or something you know
was it one heart yeah yeah i was
watching that pay-per-view live with my
friends uh and it was crazy they just
like pulled the camera away owen heart
was he [ __ ] died yeah these wrestlers
man
we [ __ ] their bodies like we have to
try my [ __ ] body hurts from traveling
imagine these dudes are doing that with
just wrestling and working out
hit you with a chair all that [ __ ] i hop
on the elliptical and i'm like [ __ ]
these dudes are doing real [ __ ] i mean
yeah that was i remember when he died i
remember being like what the [ __ ] i know
they so they're just like
he did a stunt heat from the top from
the rafters he was supposed to like come
down and it broke is that what did yeah
i didn't even know that and hold it up
one second
hold i didn't know he died that way i
thought he was a od or something
oh [ __ ] is this the is this the actual
this is a fan attacking a wrestler oh
fun yeah man all right so what do you
want to see
man i want heart dying yeah hilarious
the wrestler's just doing the wrestling
moves and the guy's just like yeah this
doesn't hurt yeah
yeah he's fine
he's like boom
yeah the the slam down on the floor i
never got wrestling i got it but it but
you were hulk hogan for halloween you
must have got i just thought it was a
funny thing he had the old n-word
scandal so he was like hot again
but this was before this was then that
was recent yeah it was probably like
six years ago oh really yeah
what uh but i never got like once i hit
puberty wrestling kind of fizzled for me
i probably liked it until i was like 17
or something i was pretty late
states 1871.
all right what are we doing here
here we go
1999
more than 84 million dollars this wasn't
even like a wrestlemania this is how
much money this [ __ ] made even then yeah
yeah right vince mcmahon won't pay these
[ __ ] health insurance no and
he's making that kind of money that's
that shit's evil yeah i mean his defense
that would be a crazy bunch of bills
though
you got you got to give something man of
course think about how rich he is
on their backs i think you gotta you
gotta support the entertainers i mean i
make the argument like
you make the same argument like club
owners don't have to pay comics yeah i
mean like we're the ones doing we're the
ones putting the bodies in seats we're
the ones you know yeah was vince mcmahon
a wrestler no because he has that great
look for owning a wrestling corporation
like
like woody allen dude
that's what i'm saying
it's just a perfect
casting like that just worked out that
he doesn't look like uh
he did when he was younger
younger he doesn't look that shredded
okay okay he got he's on roids i mean
it's like insane
oh just look up vince mcmahon ripped and
you're gonna be like what the [ __ ] i'm
too old to be this ripped yeah he's kind
of like a
a cartoon dana white
look at this [ __ ] wow
that's [ __ ] stupid perfect casting
he's all oiled up too
yeah he is he had when he had that feud
with stone cold i mean did you watch
that at all no no dude can we matt
peters can we pull some of this up are
we going to get
demonetized
pull up stone cold versus uh is it real
or no but they [ __ ] it's hilarious
it's theater maybe it's all theater yeah
this is somehow gayer than broadway
theater
yo what's gay singing a song in unison
or just shirtlessly rubbing each other
oiled up with pink tights on
uh oh man he was a phenom like he came
he changed the whole country oh dude he
was getting hammered while he's doing it
he's in handcuffs
look at this [ __ ] guy
this guy looks like he owns the the club
in miami
let's get this under control
he got the henchman blocking the cage
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
the boss he's beating up the boss
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's in politics now
i did jim and sam with him once what he
does politics he's like he does
something some small city in tennessee i
think that's hilarious he's like a mayor
of some town in tennessee
i guess it's the same [ __ ] you know just
getting people on your side riling them
up beating the opponent i thought it was
weird when he opened his speeches with
let me tell you something brother
and then he hit the other guy with a
chair
yeah
well i mean vince mcmahon's wife ran for
senate i think or something she went for
something she was pretty close
connecticut connecticut yeah it was
it's [ __ ] wild
yeah i mean don't forget arnold was uh
you know governor yeah reagan was was an
actor for sure it's crazy so it's all
[ __ ] it's all [ __ ] jessie
ventura jesse ventura
aoc was in porn
uh so it was nancy pelosi ooh
nancy reagan to hear this [ __ ] i did
what's going on she was the throat goat
of her day i claim oh
just say yes
[Laughter]
the other one said she gave the best
[ __ ] wow hollywood which it must
have kept ronald young yeah yeah yeah
gipper
[Laughter]
she was the dipper um
this guy's running for
governor of herschel walker there was a
football player a football player no
this is his son uh-oh and this is him
yesterday complaining
oh he but his but his dad is running
it's not i thought it was him oh really
oh maybe no i'm pretty sure it's hershel
walker so he's wearing a twelve hundred
dollar givenchy sweatshirt it looks like
that too
[Music]
screw your humidity you think this is
unifying just keeps going up he's
blaming biden for gas prices oh wow he's
a conservative
that is pretty hilarious that's funny
i mean look he's got good comic timing
no one can take that away sure the way
he goes disgusting
i hate you yeah
that these are the debates you want to
see yes you want to put him against
hunter
oh that's the debate oh yeah
because
you disgust me
you're trash
hunter's like look you want a line
let's just take it easy
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] speaking of did you see that
succession for now oh
did i see that finale i watched it twice
unreal watch it twice well i watched the
back half twice because it was so moving
it dude it's great tv so a great team
they
profile on jeremy strong did you read
that no he got so much buzz is he
kendall yeah yeah no he won the emmy
last year he's great but they did a new
yorker profile on him and it got a lot
of it seemed like the guy who wrote it
it's really a funny piece but it seems
like the guy who wrote it had kind of a
vendetta against him they went i think
they both went to yale or something and
he was a couple years younger and it
seemed like he never liked them but
kendall i mean jeremy strong is like a
journeyman actor i mean you kind of got
to respect it he's paid his dues he's
done a lot of small parts but then he
starts writing about his commitment and
there's parts where you're like this is
kind of hilarious i guess he plays uh in
one movie he plays big short as i recall
he's in the big show okay he's in um
another adam mckay movie too he's in uh
he's into uh aaron sorkin movies he's in
[ __ ] social network no uh
i don't know i'm sure it's it you can
look at that picture by the way yeah
it's a great picture but he dude he's
very he's like he's obsessed with like
dustin hoffman he almost bank corrupted
the uh theater company he was in because
he got them to like have al pacino come
out to accept an award he just wanted to
meet pacino
but then they talked about these it's a
movie with robert downey jr i think it
was uh he plays like an autistic younger
brother and he showed up to a day he
wasn't called to set and just cried in
the background
like he's that committed he wants to
make you like you know whoa oh he did
one well molly's game molly's game he's
good at molly's game that's a good movie
is it good yeah he directed i liked it
idris elba and jessica chastain i liked
it a lot true story i think it's great
but then he uh he's also in um
[ __ ] what's it called uh
a movie oh the new aaron sorkin movie i
didn't see it the trial of the chicago
seven i saw it and well he claims he
like they claimed he wanted to be uh
tear gas for real uh and it was a
question yeah it was a quote from uh
sorkin who was like look i want i don't
like saying no to jeremy
but you know he you know i
i'd have to tear gas like 250 people so
i had to this is like literally what
he's requesting and he's like no i don't
want to hurt any other but so like all
these stories it's like madness his
commitment to the craft you've quoted
like brian cox he's on succession where
he's like i just wish he would take it
easy on himself it sounds like they're
annoyed with the method he is
but then also you know aaron sorkin
released a letter being like he's i love
him michael yeah i sound like i'm trash
and i think he's a great actor like
i mean he's used him in two movies so
clearly he likes him so i think his cast
seems like a little annoyed that he's so
method but like you watch the show and
you're like he's incredible the results
are [ __ ] amazing amazing the crying
scene he's so layered they had a scene
in the latest season about him talking
to a reporter and he's like you're not
gonna
[ __ ] me up on this are you and she's
like no no and i wonder if that was a
little nod to this
wasn't that your thought mark that like
no one ever is a method actor who's like
goofy it's always like some serious guy
who wants to get mace in the face that
wasn't that what's your point i didn't
like rodney he's like he's he's method
the whole time yeah yeah i had a bit
about this back in the day i never did
anything with it but it was like always
someone like brando it's like you're
never like did you know for three months
rob schneider was a european jiggler
that was one of the angles i had
it's always yeah but
for sure it's you know these
okay
there's a story they tell about dustin
hoffman lawrence olivier and hoffman's
like i stayed up three nights for this
role and the famous olivier quote is my
son have you tried acting
that's great so it's like yeah there was
a part of me but like look it's hard not
to respect the dude who takes this [ __ ]
that seriously but also
you know don't do it at the you know
expense of your co-workers either of
course of course yeah it makes everyone
else uncomfortable
yeah are you but then you see this
servicing the project by doing this did
you see that did you watch the show
i did not watch the finale yet it's
[ __ ] all i'll say is it's [ __ ]
excellent there's this show gets better
and better better and better the writing
is so realistic you feel like it's
happening and it's written it's amazing
jesse armstrong is i think he's like a
[ __ ] incredible writer yeah that dude
he wrote peep show i can't believe oh
that's right two different shows yeah
they're both great so different so great
it's shakespearean the whole thing the
twist the turns the the corruption it's
incredible that's what this article says
they're saying he plays this as hamlet
yes people think he's joking but he's
happy but that's funny because he's so
serious so like we left non-stop i was
dying laughing connor is so funny too
and uh rome has some great lines but i
don't know have you seen it
no actually oh yeah
i'm a big fan buckle up because it's a
doozy uh joe list said uh billions of
successions for [ __ ]
i like billions too i've never watched
billy billings is good
i was on billions compliments that's
right that's right
he stands by it
it's it's good it's really good
uh soda is great on it our boy dan soda
zelda's on it yeah damian lewis
incredible on the show it's really good
all right all right i'll i'll try it
again
i like giamatti oh it's fine dude it's
very new york yeah yeah copperman and
levine wrote rounders they're great
that's true love rounders no i think
billions is fun man every time i walk
down the street with soda it's a black
guy's like oh [ __ ] billions black people
love billions
[Laughter]
well dude magic johnson tweeted it was
his favorite show i mean like i'm same
with dominique wilkins you're like all
these like nba legends are like
billions you go kind of cool yeah
speaking of the thing with the method
acting and the the uh american gigolo
that's a great joke
i feel the same with trans
you never see a like a guy who
transitions you guys see him tightening
right here oh it's not bad you never see
someone transition to a woman and then
be like a chick in a hoodie
you know what i mean it's always like a
caricature of a woman it's never like
like my girl walks around and you know
jeans and a t-shirt but you never see
that caricature but they but like a
bigger woman rather than like you know
like they hit the stereotypes it's very
feminine it's very lady-ish you know if
you just become if you just become a
woman you're going to want to enjoy it
probably is that what it is i think the
sweatshirt is like a jaded woman
who's like i'm not going through the
makeup i think if you always wanted to
be a woman i always felt you were a
woman right you're going all the way
you're like i'm gonna be a woman why
don't we ask the other woman in the room
yeah there's a lady here i'm thinking
there's gotta be like weekends at home
where caitlyn jenner is just watching
netflix and i guess you're right pjs i
mean yeah scruffy probably i don't know
yeah no you're right we see i mean you
see it on the outside if you're a
prominent trans person you kind of have
to bring it
right you're representing your whole
group
but like elliot page
has a 12 pack you know and you're like
sure you had to go all shredded you
couldn't just be you couldn't be a
doughy you couldn't be george costanza i
feel body shamed by her body there you
go i see her 12 pack and i'm like you
have to get do you have to do it that
quickly aha good point that's
insensitive to this flabby jew so
i saw a headline about him on cnn and it
was like quit thirst trapping elliot i
was like can you really write this about
somebody on cnn like it's a weird first
even weirder it was chris cuomo
[Laughter]
what are they doing right now are the
cuomo just having a big pursuing cnn are
they i think he's going to get money
dude for what
for firing him
i think they had just caused
we'll see i mean
this is what lawyers do right i mean
like he's i think he's trying to get 18
mil
oh like what's left on his contract
maybe i think so yeah i think it's fine
i think it's very possible he'll get
something i think he will too because he
didn't do anything well i mean he didn't
well there was a sexual misconduct
allegations there was yeah also his
purdue but like his producer like did
you hear about that yeah what happened
his producer was like grooming young
girls lady or man he's a guy oh and when
you see his picture you're gonna be like
yep oh i don't like the profile but take
a look at this guy he's no jazlane huh
so yeah
he wishes he had her hair
oh really
this is our guy
hey folks we might be drunk is brought
to you by manscaped oh yeah set your
first new year's resolution
with good intentions and join the four
million men worldwide who trust manscape
with our exclusive offer go to
manscape.com and use promo code drunk
for 20 off plus free
shipping holy hell
i love manscape i use the ball wash i
shave with the uh the lawnmower it's
good stuff it gets it in tight i keep it
in my travel bag i just whenever i need
it it's all there you got the crop
preserver crop reviver uh you got the
lawnmower 4.0 it's got a light on it for
chrysix i love this thing they love it
they even uh they they have a travel bag
i still use boxer briefs are great and
uh the ultra premium body wash is great
for manscaped love manskip i used to use
their shampoo and conditioner if i'm
being honest yeah yeah oh yeah i use it
today that's where this [ __ ] load of
bird's nest came from but yeah get it
get on it folks
yeah i got some of that shampoo in my in
my uh shower too hey whether your
resolution is to work out more or to
travel to new places be sure to travel
to manscape.com
for our exclusive offer of 20 off plus
free shipping with the code drunk that's
20 off and free shipping with the code
drunk at manscape.com
one last time one last time sorry i've
been drinking
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com use the code drunk it's the
new year no pubes in 2022
with manscaped support the show and get
20 off from free shipping with the code
drunk at manscape.com hell yeah get on
it man and look better and smell better
we gotta figure out the height on the
cuomo brothers because they vary
sometimes chris is taller sometimes
andrew's taller no andrew's taller look
it up i need numbers really
luring young girls luring is never good
luring is never good unless it's on a
fishing pole
it's never good it's not good for the
fish
the person being lowered is never good
look at this guy holy [ __ ] so he invited
guys
huh he invited a mom
and her daughter
and he was going to train them both in
dominance wow and the fbi got wind of it
and was like you're going to jail holy
hell
yeah cnn is is like can one of you guys
not do any of this stuff yeah
oh yeah now uh don lemon's uh i heard
don is in trouble too yeah that's it's i
mean here's the thing like there's
there's this you know it's just bad when
when brian williams is like i'm walking
away
right right you know just bad when he's
like i'm out was he the guy who lied
yeah but the helicopter yeah he pulled
around as easy on our ass
look at the white uh smallett
[Laughter]
i mean jesse don't you feel that if he
was like a slightly better actor he
would have gotten away with it
like denzel wouldn't have gotten caught
if it was daniel day lewis you're like
he would have [ __ ] believe me he would
have pulled it off yeah you [ __ ]
don't you're telling me there will be
blood daniel day-lewis gonna duped us
so did he got a point did you see the
thing uh what made the cops suspicious
of the story immediately
was that he came home with his subway
sandwich
yeah and the cops were like that's
strange
because like
he does he eats subway yeah why would he
do this to himself this man clearly
hates himself this is the type of man
who would hire people to beat the [ __ ]
out of it right right
wow subway is dog [ __ ] subways i got
into the rest stop recently and i was
like this is the worst this is worse
than getting really beaten up by two
dudes and maga hats that's how bad this
is pour the bleach on me
this is not real meat those sandwiches
are worse than what jared did
get that clip
[Laughter]
oh
man those are the worst i knew they were
lying to us uh when when they tried to
pass that [ __ ] off as avocado ah i know
right it comes out of a bag it's all
weird and neon yeah the whole thing is
trash
that's yoga mat bread it is it's
styrofoam now remember when we thought
subway was healthy i ate it every day
for like two years
i thought it was held on five dollars
filling i get that chicken teriyaki
can i get another one of these or is
that crazy
oh sorry i looked at that livery from
subway now
eat forever
is way better than subway i agree of the
big three in in the wars of sandwiches
blimpy cuisno's
uh jersey mike and subways jersey mike's
is pretty terrible i think i don't know
jersey mike it's pretty bad wait you're
not gonna throw jimmy john a bone oh
jimmy john too i i say quiznos is the
best and jimmy john's the second best of
those to me what do you think
interesting quiz knows it's weird cause
subway is the most popular
isn't that weird that's kind of a they
were great at advertising everything was
smart remember clay henry too remember
that put look up clay henry jingle he
got real big on burger and fries and oh
yeah
smaller size clay henry see how good
that advertising is that was years ago i
remembered that [ __ ] it stuck in
that's good advertising great jingle
writing is the jingle dead by the way no
okay i love a good jingle
colombia south carolina
[Music]
with the help of exercising they really
should have stuck with him instead of
jail i know right a fireman some guy in
the boardroom's like no we gotta ride
this jared thing out he's like are you
sure clay henry's a fireman they're like
nah
it hurts jared did do his thing
wait that sounds bad
he did you know make him huge for a
while but he didn't sound good either
they should make an hbo show about jared
it's like the real jared where he's just
like doing tours i mean like you guys
too can lose weight cut to a hotel room
oh [ __ ]
he's snorting out of a diaper
he's got a rattle
[Laughter]
he's doing lines but with the monopoly
money rolled up
oh [ __ ]
your move
[Laughter]
this is a dark f oh yeah this is going
to get us in trouble this is gonna we're
gonna lose some ads huh yeah what about
um
quiznos is great quiznos is [ __ ] i
remember adele used to uh have a joke
about a guy in the middle east i don't
remember his name it was something with
a lot of cues using eyes i called him
quiznos
[Laughter]
yeah it's it's just like comedy though
the most popular people are never the
best for sure the same with the
sandwiches yeah we're quiznos baby
yeah no it's it's hilarious man that uh
subway is just trash and it's everywhere
everywhere it's gonna be going downhill
because i feel like hoagies are not as
hot as they were like they were hot for
a while new yorkers like we still eat
sandwiches but like why would you go to
subway when you can literally for this
oh basically the same money go to any
corner bodega and get a way better
sandwich a turkey on a roll at any
corner store bodega in new york is
better than the subway we're a sandwich
culture in new york oh yeah we like we
like our sandwiches i'll get a good dude
i'll get i guess i have a corner store
it's like one of those little mini
grocery stores go-to sandwich though i
do i mix it up man i do i like doing
like
uh like a turkey reuben like i think
they call it rachel but i don't [ __ ]
play that why do i have to order a
rachel [ __ ] you
i like turkey with like thousand island
or russian with uh
oh that's good coleslaw swiss melted oh
i'll do that
i go toasted dry all day i also like a
little just turkey cheddar
uh mayo
a little lettuce tomato i'll [ __ ]
keep it simple how about you guys yeah
yeah i mean turkey well first of all
american cheese in russian dressing is
great and it's good for the country you
know we got we got
it's good for politics let those two
come together no more cold war cold
sandwich cold cuts
yeah cold cuts not cold war so i'm with
you russian dressing is so underrated
i'm so so good dude i like this is a new
york thing they they chop the beef
chopped beef or minced beef
chopped cheese chopped cheese yeah it's
basically just a burger yeah oh i love
chopped cheese
it just has it's a bodega thing they're
good what are you going you you grew up
in the l-e-s
yeah i used to do cats is before it
became a commercial you know like
commercial but it's still great i was
there since i was like a child but those
finishes are still cash money i still if
i'm nearby in the a winter canish get
the [ __ ] out of here yeah yeah what's
your what's your sandwich though
um i like turkey brie and honey mustard
that's like my go-to that's great it's a
great sandwich oh that point you went
full white girl
yeah exactly
sally what's yours
uh i do like a chopped cheese but like
you can't eat that every day no yeah
it's like once a month so just a regular
turkey sandwich i like turkey too
chicken breast i could [ __ ] with too
sure egg sandwich you know what else is
big in new york is that a bacon egg
cheese
just on a roll in the morning that
breakfast sandwich oh classic classic
that was a cup of coffee whoa get that
[ __ ] in a croissant too if you want to
be a bad little boy come on we're in
everything bagel holy [ __ ] oh my god
you're talking crazy what uh
oh man i got a good wreck for you this
ties right into my wreck hit me baby all
right this is a good wreck i think and
it's norman's gonna [ __ ] love it oh
winter soups
in new york they hit different if you
live in a cold city in the winter
winter soups hit different like if you
get like uh [ __ ] a lentil or something
in my moons or you get a uh good chicken
noodle or a [ __ ]
hey man some ramen who gives a [ __ ] yeah
maybe some uh my personal favorite
borscht a hot boy
not so much for me but a hot porsche
get the [ __ ] out of here look nachos i
like yeah chilled chilled gazpacho you
think you understand this [ __ ] if you're
in a warm climate right now chilled
gazpacho get out of here you're fooling
yourself
soup is not supposed to be refreshing
it's supposed to you're supposed to go
ah yes it's hearty it should be warming
your soul you're supposed to react to a
soup similarly to the way you come
you're supposed to be like
yeah not like
it's chilly
come on
yeah good call i mean a tortilla soup a
chicken vegetable a matzo balm
soup cheese and soup french onion that's
all it is yesterday oh yeah
the jew the jews back baby it's coming
out
[Laughter]
wait till after later when i drink a
little bit more then i'll be puerto
rican again there you go
sober day tortilla see [ __ ] good
that's the way to do it jew in the
streets puerto rican in the sheets yes
that's right get your bills paid and
then party
yeah soups are good uh did you send my
agent sent me a bunch of soups for
christmas you know your agent sent you
like
christmas dude was that you no okay
because my age has been calling around
like hey what is mark like and i got
eight gallons of whiskey so i was like
no more booze i got enough booze and
somebody said get the [ __ ] some
soup and they nailed it
so what kind of shoes they got me these
jars of soup you know some lady in
upstate new york makes their own batch
and all that [ __ ] what kind oh i can't
think of the name of it oh but we got a
it was four of them it was minestrone
classic it was uh clam chowder
it was manhattan and new england
i think it was new england i hate to say
it there's the one area boston beats us
totally and i hate to i hate to admit it
but a good sport knows when we've lost
and new york's better than boston but
you guys do a better clam shadow and
lobster hole interesting i think it's
fair to say
noble yeah
four playoffs
pedro throwing don zimmer eat [ __ ] dude
uh [ __ ] that was disrespectful you're
not
saying when the best team won that year
they were a good team david ortiz was
was more clutch than a-rod that was a
problem
oh sorry what's the guy's name paul no
o'neill not paul o'neill what's the guy
with the long hair johnny damon johnny
damon
guy that guy turned code on the red sox
that's the dirt he did he did yeah he
came here and he kind of sucked he was a
very patient hitter i always liked i i
still love baseball but yeah there he is
come on what the [ __ ] it was in the
geico commercials
[Music]
what a pull
oh that's a that's a man he hit he hit a
grand slam when i was in game seven he
[ __ ] raped our mothers right in front
of us oh yeah i was watching that in
college and it was a big deal that was
brutal oh yeah
but yeah soups hot soups hot soups all
day
get that chilled [ __ ] out of here good
wreck
i'll even [ __ ] with a good miso man i
love a miso love hot and sour love egg
drop bring them all on i dropped some
chunks
you got a favorite
i do but it's in la and it's a chain
actually they haven't i got in atlanta
it's just called jinya ramen
jin jin uh j-i-n
yeah
yeah yeah
no gin ramen oh there it is it's
different though
it's
it's crazy good you get like a creamy
broth it's oh dude
it's on another level you get some
[ __ ]
nice uh sauteed broccolini in there you
get your uh you get your little uh they
put like those special eggs i don't know
i don't even know how they're cooked
it's not quite poached it's like not
quite hard boiled [ __ ] it is i know holy
[ __ ] it gets all the [ __ ] wet and all
the dick's hard that's all i know
junior
yeah dude wonder what that means what
does jinya mean i don't know let's look
it up
dumb jew i'm like wow that's crazy
let's see
popularity
oh sorry wrong thing wait jr oh a type
of administrative headquarters ah so
it's kind of like hey we're the soup
capital yes okay that's clever yeah
all right
talk about a bigger progress than ramen
then we talk about progress in this
country
ramen and weed
weed was a gateway drug it was a [ __ ]
uh you know reefer madness and it went
put you in jail it was illegal and now
weed is like
medical it's business it's uh it's huge
it's crazy that there are people in jail
for selling weeds i know
and it's like now like can you imagine
being in jail for selling weed and then
there's just legal weed it's insane
it's kind of [ __ ] up i mean they got
to let them out let them out let them
out and give them a weed business you
know like we should give them something
yeah they were trailblazers yeah
literally
played basketball for the nba yeah
that was their team they were they were
nicknamed the jailblazers
[Music]
and then think about ramen was like i
went to public school it was like you
know a bunch of poor kids and they all
had their ramen they would eat it hard
you remember that yeah i've done it's
gross it's gross but it was like
yeah yeah it was jail we all were just
snacking on that [ __ ] we were they were
11 cents you know you got shrimp i got
chicken i got spicy beef and it was
great chicken was the best chicken was
the best yeah yeah shrimp was weird but
now ramen is this like upscale genia you
know there's an egg in it
yeah it's good man i like it man it's
especially if you're sick i mean like
you get if you're sick for like a week
you get you get real tired of chicken
noodle soup yes i don't want to only
call chicken noodle soup when i'm sick
it turns into like a [ __ ] you're like
you it's an unhealthy dynamic why am i
only showing up when things are bad
you're a good suit i'm abusing the
relationship good point let's mix it up
i'll get some other soups i like a
little hot and sour cleans up the
sinuses i like a little a little ramen
delightful get your protein still
tom yum has nothing to sneeze at either
yeah that's all right oh i love a tom
yum it's that weird flavor it's got the
mushrooms in it the chicken mushrooms
are underappreciated good mushroom
barley soup
that's a great soup mark's a slurper
dude yeah [ __ ] he
[ __ ] slurps like he lives in
asia
yeah i got my half one lip on the bowl
one lip on this broth
oh i bring it right to the mouth how
about this move how about just drinking
it like it's a glass of tea or something
you gotta give it a few spoons you can't
go right to the tea yeah you gotta you
gotta eat that [ __ ] a little bit before
you're going for the [ __ ] right exactly
get it all hot and steamy
you gotta get out of here
no oh oh okay
throwing on something does that do
anything come on for warmth yeah it does
really this is a good one because it's
oh [ __ ] oh i like those oh hey man so i
just i have one of those from my neck i
just it was i'm a big scarf guy but i
like the thing that you pulled down over
your head and it's that material oh i
lost it broke my heart left in a [ __ ]
hotel room somewhere god knows where you
forget where you even are i order it
can't find it on amazon so i'm like you
know what this is a good sign i'm gonna
go elsewhere i shouldn't be so relying
on amazon they're an evil corporation
good for you jeff bezos lets these
[ __ ] die he's sending michael
strahan from the giants to space he's
letting these warehouse workers drop
dead he doesn't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] amazon
until i need them and yeah anyway i
ordered that thing from dick's sporting
goods what happens it said to be here
like two weeks ago yeah
i get an email from dicks there's been a
delay yeah dicks their hats [ __ ] you i'm
out we're done holy [ __ ] i tried i gave
it a chance it wasn't meant to be well
hey i mean you got to keep up we're used
to just immediate satisfaction give it
to me right here put it right in my ass
chisel my face and then hey if you're
not ready
i'm not jerking that dick
uh hello dicks you were supposed to jizz
on my face yeah i need it now well if
you don't know what that means and i
don't want to do business with you okay
yeah it's like a horned up chick she's
like come over right now and [ __ ] when
you're like oh actually um i'm helping
some girl scout sell cookie well if you
don't come over now it's over you're
like no no then you start hitting the
girl scout
you [ __ ] what the [ __ ] happened and
then i used to help this scout you
[ __ ] beat him up
[Music]
there is something like you ever you
ever with your girl and uh you order
food
and it gets it you start fooling around
and then the food gets there and you're
thinking about the food
of course and you're kind of like look i
want to do this but like look i can come
in 30 seconds i mean we're really we're
waiting on you here yeah good point the
women are really you're waiting on the
women yeah you got to pre-heat the oven
got to preheat the oven right whereas
you're a microwave a microwave 400
30 seconds let's do this yeah
so that is the thing where you're like
all right but hey man the food's still
hot you still get to get the little
thing pull the stuff
[Music]
yeah that's good there's no better
feeling than having sex and then you're
done you both come you sit on the couch
you open some chinese no that is nice
yeah
yeah that's good and it's kind of nice
because now they just leave the food
outside your door when it was and back
in the day you had to open it with like
a heart on tucked in your [ __ ]
shirt
you tuck it in your your your uh
underwear
you know yeah and and you're just like
what do you want and i'm sorry you're
like ah [ __ ] i'm coming i'm sorry
oh he's like oh i thought i would have
the egg roll
that's like a [ __ ] national lampoons
movie you're like i should i can't
control it you just jizz all over the
delivery man those books are so bad
speaking of which you mentioned straight
hands going to space yeah space is now
the new that's how bad he didn't want to
watch the giants
[Laughter]
but space is the new playboy club
you know before it was like hey
this guy's so fail he's going to a
playboy party at the playboy mansion oh
[ __ ] now it's space yeah either way
you're going to see shatner
i'll tell you this too you're right it's
it's a new playboy club black hole
had to squeeze it in
i mean
it is interesting that you're you're
totally right man there's something like
it's the new exclusive thing that's it
playboy club now is like you know
although maybe people get canceled for
going to space in like 40 years oh he
went to space when people were suffering
that'll be the news right well it's not
inclusive you know it's been like a
handful of people it's not exactly like
you know open bar over there there's
maybe maybe we'll go to mars and
there'll be like martians with three
tits and it'll be the really the new
playboy club you'll be like dude she'll
[ __ ] go out going back with this
martian shirt she's got dude she got
three three tits
four mouths and you're like whoa
you're calling friends get over here i
don't want to waste a hole
yeah the space grotto
damn dude um
do you have a diva peeve yeah yeah well
we opened the show by talking about
drunks at uh at the comedy zone great
club
ted's a great guy who runs it great guy
we got drunk on saturday really me and
him in a green room just going at it was
great i had that in arizona stand up
live with uh matt coleman who runs it we
were we were just i had a bottle of wine
i was like you're gonna make me drink
all this wine alone you know
we just down in it oh yeah i love those
nights a great night he didn't drink
with us
uh we had to coax him a little bit but
uh good egg good dude like keeps it real
he's like a comic yeah he's a good dude
great guy and uh what was i gonna say
what was that oh my peeve
so here's my peeve and this is a little
inside baseball it's comedy [ __ ] but i
gotta say to all the comics out there
enough with the
oh you guys aren't laughing i guess
you're not drunk enough yet i'm so sick
of that line first of all you don't have
to be drunk to laugh
you know you're laughing you're laughing
you guys aren't hammered
i remember a lot of memories on the
playground with with eight-year-old kids
and you know at school we were all
laughing nobody was drinking mark they
were shit-faced they were faking it they
were
no no no i know you mean dude we've been
laughing the whole time we have been
drinking honestly that's true look at
marcos you guys are all laughing we've
been drinking the whole show i pointed
to them
but no you're totally right i mean
that's like it's like a stock line it's
a stock line and it's just so much it's
so not true it's so false like you can
laugh like you go to a theater you go
see les miz and there's a funny line and
a master of the house keeper of the end
and you're laughing but you're not like
i need a cocktail you know it's just
funny yeah money's funny but uh
yeah i get what they're saying they're
like you're not loose enough
saying like you're you're too uh you
know uh you're stiff you need a real
critique on the comic though i mean i
agree you have to be drunk to appreciate
this sure yeah so he's really
insulting himself i don't yeah i mean i
don't when i'm watching a comedy at home
i can laugh like of course i was
watching the office on a flight and i
was laughing out oh by the way though
i'm next to these two guys
on my flight back
just the loudest gay couple on the
planet
they couldn't be louder and it's like
you know it's early i'm tired and
they're just like they're like oh stop
it oh come on i'm just like oh god i'm
killing maybe yeah then of course they
throw on a show and i'm like well at
least i'll quiet down now it's veep
after every line that you could just
something like
that's how much they're reacting to a tv
you even hear the rest of the story
mile high
i heard one of them jerking off in the
bathroom
this isn't virgin
you're killing me you're killing i was
so
you're in those flights where you're
just texting your girlfriend you're just
like
gay dudes loudest laughs ever
killing me
you don't get caught with that text are
you secretly like jealous of their lives
though
um i'm jealous that they feel good in
that moment i'm very irritable when i
fly because you know i'm in pain a lot
of the time i don't sleep enough yeah
but then yeah like i'm jealous that
they're enjoying their time of course
but also i'm like
literally i'm looking and also gary
veeder switched seats with me oh
so i was like all right because he was
like he's like i i accidentally booked a
flight to jfk into laguardia he's like
we should be on the same flight i was
like [ __ ] it let me try to change it so
we're at the airport i change it and
then he's like ah you didn't get like
comfort he's like oh let's switch so you
because you know oh he's a nice guy like
that then he's in the back he's like
yeah well i get the last row it wasn't
great for me either i'm having dudes
[ __ ] wave [ __ ] in my face they're
opening the door
but uh you know
but vader's so
i mean look it sucks being a short guy
you know it's hard to get laid no one
respects you you're pretty much
worthless but
it sucks he's married he gets laughed
but no one does respect them no no no
but at an
oh yeah we got to get vitor on but his
feet don't even hit the floor on an
airplane so it must be nice every seat's
extra leg room you're always in first
class you're four foot one
enjoy that gary i get it i
we're on the road in miami and uh
what's cool about miami is wherever you
go you can get a cuban coffee like even
the chain places what is it what makes
it a cube it's just way stronger oh
really strong which i love sweeter what
the cortez
yeah yeah it's really good
but we get it and we we're the dunkin
donuts and veda uh this is one i've
never seen this before we go in there
it's like there's not a lot around us so
we walk into dunkin donuts i'm like
think i'm you know i'm like a caffeine
addict i'm like i need my coffee we walk
in
and i'm dying i just need to wake up a
little i'm [ __ ] fading and then the
guy's just he's literally making like 12
sandwiches and we're like what the hell
is he we've been waiting there for like
seven minutes and we're like what is he
doing we look at each other i'm like hey
man can we just get a coffee and he goes
i got the biggest order ever i just got
to get this order done and i'm like eb
you can just pour us a coffee and but
yeah no one's even here right it's a
very big order and gary like loses he
goes this is insane he goes what are you
[ __ ] kidding me he's like you can't
borrow his two [ __ ] coffees gary
loses it i can see that i'm like well
how long are you going to be he goes at
least another 15 minutes i was like
there's no one here
gary's like this is [ __ ] outrageous
and the guy goes sir sir i specialize in
customer service i live to please the
customer and i'm just like
so gary
coming in there who's this [ __ ] uh
sandwich for castro so we're leaving
gary's like [ __ ] this guy he's losing it
he's so angry and then we walk around
the lot and it was like there's no other
coffee did you go back in we went back
in i was like gary we gotta go back in
you should have put the order before you
left
two blacks
let's just go back in we'll apologize
i'm like you were really the rude one
he's like all right i'll apologize
and then we walk in and gary's i'm like
we're very sorry he goes no i'm sorry
he's like i live to please customers i
customer service my whole life i lived
to please you guys were like thank you
guys just a few more minutes i'll make
you a special coffee i'm like no just a
regular coffee is fine i'll make it
special you're gonna spit in it exactly
he literally takes a while they're
foaming he brings them out and i'm just
looking at him and he's like i made
these with love
oh he came in here
[Music]
drink that gary looks at me and he just
he shakes his head he's like no
we're making this skit making the skit
yeah
he's like no and i'm like no no no no
man i don't i don't want i'm like thank
you very much we walk out we just dump
it in the garbage i'm like what the [ __ ]
do we do for coffee now burnt a half
hour for nothing but you got the story
brutal so did you find coffee
there we got like a shitty one at the
hotel oh that stinks what are you gonna
do man that's a peeve
these i got a very specific beef yeah
but i gotta pee for you go to chipotle
you go to you know uh just salad
whatever it is quiznos the online orders
have now dominated the guy in the room
you go to chipotle and you go the guy's
making 18 burritos i'm like hey i'm here
and he's like hold on i got 38 grub hubs
coming you're like what about me i'm
here you know it's like your your
girlfriend texting and you're like i'm
here
talk to me and you're eating her [ __ ]
yeah you're [ __ ] texting you're like
faces right
yeah i'm like hey
i'm going with the bib on
yeah that's it's tough it's like grubhub
is dominating now the live customer you
don't see a lot of bibs anymore
ah lobster is the last lobster's the
last bib and i'll tell you man love a
lobster [ __ ] love a lobster baby you're
in heaven it's funny because the food is
so expensive that it allows you to look
like trash
because it's a it's a good um
juxtaposition you're right you couldn't
go eat at
a denny's with a bib on you'd look like
a psycho but if it's lobster they go
well you can afford lobster so he's uh
he's on the up and up hmm
lobster man if you if you get it the
right way still
there's nothing but i know it was like
peasant food back in the day oh yeah you
know boston if you go to like one of
those romaine or or oh if you're right
off the water the best you get a good
lobster roll or a good lobster [ __ ] i
mean you do have to work hard for it a
lobster is kind of like a woman where
you're just like she's like we're gonna
it's gonna be eight dates
but then that eighth night you're like
oh this is this is good and it smells of
the sea
but
put lobster on my list ramen lobster
weed they all started from nothing yeah
and they turn to this you know expensive
high-end uh
thing you consume
i love it yeah yeah lobster what do you
think lobster claw is underrated too
yeah i found this place in rhode island
where they just give you like
lobster cubes and they fry them up they
like take the best of it so you don't
want to do the lobster yeah it's so
interesting that seems like nuggets it's
kind of like a nugget it is so funny
lightly fried or lightly fried okay okay
lightly
yes and i mean we went there every day
for this almost everything deep fry
avocado at this place
what the [ __ ] are you doing deep fry
nothing i don't know any better exactly
it's perfect
yeah nothing like getting that out of
that pit out
now you love that i feel like a magician
when i hit that with a knife and then
you
ah that's a great feeling deep frying
lobster is like getting fake tits when
you already have amazing tits oh there
you go
yeah oh fake tits those are we have to
fake this oh you left it here mark i
forgot it i thought i thought that was
going to be like your travel companion
there well i came so
i finished
what's your wreck oh
yeah what is my wreck well my wreck
sucks
i feel bad but i'm reading
what's the book i'm reading a book uh
look this up it's called uh
what's it called
i'm wrong so much i don't want to be
right uh bernie brillstein's book oh wow
it's incredible he was a legend legend
agent he was a comedy agent in like the
80s 90s and recently but he
if it's died
the company though yeah brillstein
uh
what is it called i can't think of the
name something about it where did i go
right where'd i go right that's it
where'd i go right and it talked about
him growing up in new york and then him
his dysfunctional family
is like [ __ ] up and crazy but it's
perfect for comedians so he learned how
to deal with crazy people young so he
went right into comedy and it was a
perfect transition wow and it's a great
book new york guy jewish guy went to l.a
does the whole thing mail room at
william morris all that it's like the
archetype story and just became the best
it's crazy it says perfect transition
and uh it's from elliot page right there
that's great uh no no he's a legend i've
i've heard so much about him so this is
a great wreck mark he had everybody you
know he had sandler at one point and
then he had mel brooks and i'm talking
about brooks is a book out oh does he
yeah he does the audiobook too oh
he's one of those guys 15 hours which in
your 90s you're like that's a big
commitment yeah well he's still working
that guy is still going
yeah legend legend read an article about
how he met i don't know if it was in the
new york magazine or new yorker i forgot
it might have been new york magazine
where how he met anne bancroft he met
her by heckling her at a show where she
was singing you've heard this she was in
new york magazine in new york magazine
my wife works there it's a great story
she did that story it's great yes great
story beautiful photo too really let's
see it okay wow he heckled her at the
show
she's way out of his league yeah for
sure and uh and he was like oh man like
and she goes and who the hell are you he
goes oh i'm a nobody and she goes oh i
know who you are i have your tapes uh
2000 year old man so he literally
heckles her singing and she was like oh
i know you then he wouldn't leave her
alone yeah
he literally stalked her but she it was
like back when stalking was okay it was
normal that was tinder
that's without dating apps and dms
that's like right women back in the day
you just harassed them relentlessly
right you were you were persistent at
the gym there you go
that's all you had
oh that's a beautiful photo wow they're
adorable look at that she still looks
good by the way she's dead dude
are you kidding me she died like a long
time ago really who am i thinking of
ellen mirren
oh
yeah she looks great she died a long
time ago ellen mirren no oh
no i guess that's next topic wait this
is mrs robinson right yes yes dead she
died 15 years ago ovarian cancer or
something like that
i mean fun fact you know how old she was
is mrs robinson
36.
that was a minute that was a milf back
then i'm 38. me too
yeah you're you're you're over the hill
you're done
but no you still look great but it's
just it's funny that that was the
the uh
the milf the milf like oh she's an old
lady 36 now milf is like 67 you're like
how does that even i know i know the
math works but i guess jane fonda looks
amazing you still hit it oh [ __ ] yeah
i mean for the story hell yeah grayson
frankie you're the frankie
[Laughter]
yeah she looks great i mean i'm worried
about her i'm like hey lady uh get out
of the the botox place for one minute
will ya but she looks good yeah hanging
in there she's lucid she's still acting
full head of hair legend legend can i
give a wreck sure please licorice pizza
is it good
dude it's paul thomas andrew it's a
movie oh
oh sorry i've been drinking i thought
that was a food i was like you kids with
your weed and your gummies no ronald our
boy it was like it's not good what is he
talking about i can't wait to see it i'm
dying to see he's a movie buff
self-proclaimed he's ronan
is one of my best friends he's a [ __ ]
hater dude he's a hater he hates
anything unless it's like miserable like
he'll like like florida project he'll
likely which i love i mean and we got to
get simon rex on the show because he's
oh yeah he's got all kinds of oscar buzz
for red rocket his new movie that
director's new article about him in new
york as well i would love to get rex on
i'm happy for the guy a very nice guy
and it's like cool that he's like
getting a show out how good an actor he
is devil i did his pod me too man oh so
yeah we got to get him on he loves us
um yeah i saw him at the seller the
other night we you saw him too
so he was the biggest laugher in the
room that night well i needed it
licorice pizza paul thomas anderson
it's great where did you watch it uh
lincoln center
so it's in theaters yeah 70 millimeter
projector
nice it's like 70s ecstasy critic
critics i mean ronald hated it but
critics say it's great
what's with ron on it i don't i don't
can't even see something not to like
about ronald hated whiplash
oh okay well he's a [ __ ] hater i
liked it so much i came home from the
theater and watched heart eight with
stacey i was like now we got to watch
this i've never seen it oh but it's good
it's really good yeah casino right
what's that casino flick yes yes and
it's uh john c riley and phillip baker
hall and and what's her name uh
melissa leo no
that was the cooler
yeah no that was
maria bello ah that's what i thought the
cooler is good cooler is
was hot really
oh so hot hey i did we hide a joke at
william macy not being the lead he's a
lead in that [ __ ] movie exactly he
carries it and guess who the supporting
is sorry baldwin that's right i think i
know nom for that [ __ ]
but i mean hey uh william h carries
fargo
oh yeah he's amazing no he's amazing
he's always supportive but no he's an
amazing actor but uh
and uh
sam jackson he also the scene where alec
baldwin's actually he's beating the [ __ ]
out of someone he actually lost control
and really beat the [ __ ] out of that he
actually shot someone i lost control and
caught someone too it was a joke i was
making oh i'm sorry
i'm triggered
all right it's a loose cannon what can i
say okay what uh
wait what were you talking about
uh you said something licorice pizza
yeah before i'm going to see it dude
boogie nights i'll go see one of my
favorites i would like to see that as
well we should make a patreon app before
we go to that make some popcorn let's do
i hate why did i just say mandate
man cave mandate let me blow my [ __ ]
head off real quick
please bring you another little treat of
something oh no more booze just uh
because you know the patron guys love
you obviously and this is a a neat pour
of their new anejo that's aged two and a
half years in sherry barrels
[Music]
all right hey jamie works with liquor i
should tell you that at home jamie we
love you thank you so much try that new
thing that's just a little extra treat
for you all right thank you
i have one for you too
you just have a sip man
bartender
just just not just dude i'm going i'm
gonna drink plenty of this man it's a
fascinating scent
it sits like a whiskey
that's weird
it's like very bitter
you're getting because it's a dry sherry
barrel that it's aged in whoa
that is fascinating no kick really
either it doesn't have that like
yeah dry sherry worst porn name ever
sally's back no kick dead baby all right
this is good that would be good in like
manhattan or an old-fashioned really yes
this is pretty interesting it's now i
think it took a couple sips because it's
not what i was expecting it's pretty
damn good you can get it in an old
fashioned actually now in um bar room i
believe
i i've it's like one of the some of the
bars are already doing it it's an anejo
yeah tequila mm-hmm
fried portraits
of good stuff yeah if you get a tequila
aniejo is yeah oh i thought the silver
was good because there's no hangover
just tell us the price
that's how i know if it's good or not
it's up there it's up there patron is
good stuff though right oh yes all right
that's all i drink now yeah
i i mean i love scotch i love whiskey i
love bourbon but patron it's just
clean
one lime squeeze you're good maybe a
splash of soda and the hangover is
pretty pretty easy
yeah i do a lot of wine on the road do a
lot of vodka in the road because it's
just you know it's simple yeah
it is but you do get sometimes you go
too hard the night before and you do
feel that like low
oh yeah [ __ ] but wine no no club has
good wine i feel like dude some of these
clubs just get it for me oh okay
they'll just do the uh the natural [ __ ]
and it's like the hangover is nothing
for that really it's it's the it's the
natural stuff so you're not natural it's
good yeah orange wine speaking of clubs
getting stuff for you what are your
riders can you tell us about yeah what
do you got what's in your what's your
name what's in your contract that a
club's got to have for you i
don't i'm not a writer guy
i'm right or die you know i just show up
i do my jokes i get drunk i leave i high
five everybody i call him a horrible
slur and i run out of the building i
didn't have a ride until i worked with
gary veeder and he was like you don't
have a rider he's like you could be
getting a rider yeah and he was like you
need to have fresh fruit in here and i
was like all right fresh fruit
you heard all these horror stories about
uh eddie griffin comes in and he demands
a new pair of jordans and he doesn't
even take him he just makes you get them
and all right he'll dunk him in the
[ __ ] champagne ice box afterwards
yeah i don't i don't love that so i
don't want to be that guy i want to be
like just the guy who comes in give me a
cup of coffee coffee coffee
fruit you'll be walking out with a
bottle to something every night coffee
yeah but you can't fly with it anyway
coffee fruit and uh
pepto
because the club's got the booze so i
don't really need booze
but if if they offer some clubs just
give you like a bottle of whiskey or
wine and like that's usually what i'll
drink is whiskey or wine has anyone ever
asked for drugs
i've had i have yeah you that's how i
got drugged
that's how i got fentanyl oh god damn it
mark if you [ __ ] die and i'm stuck
doing this podcast we're just sad
accused no one's gonna listen uh
well you get somebody else in here but
wait no i go bananas
uh
a granola bar
and
simple tequila which i already took off
the list because you're right it's
already there
now you put it important big comics yeah
what are what's in their room oh my god
schumer had lagerville and i remember
she went live and this is great scotch
she had a pd scotch a fruit bar with a
with a
a blender
she had have a blender she could make a
smoothie
remember jlo said like all the walls
have to be covered with white sheets
yikes yeah like she was like doing a
decorating thing that was like
that's like a rally
i don't know white sheets i don't get it
it's just she didn't want to look at
shitty walls and bad artworks and she
was like cover everything with white so
i don't have to look at anything that's
my guess that sounds like a lot yeah
it's a lot i heard a fun eye thing from
a rock star i forgot who like a dave
groll type not him but somebody like him
where he's so famous he's so popular
everybody wants a photo everybody wants
an autographer wants to talk to him that
he does a rule where he goes
try to be a nice guy try to talk to
everybody but sometimes you have a bad
day sometimes you're hungover sometimes
you're fighting with your wife whatever
it is so he puts his hood up and if his
hood's up don't talk to him
if it's not up i'm um open game come
over say hello shake my hand weirdly
he's in the clan
but yeah i thought that was a pretty
good move i was like
at least you let people know you're not
like ellen where you're like ellen you
want this cough
i'll kill you helen
yeah yeah exactly
so at least you let them know and paul
mccartney dana gould told this story
paul mccartney he met at conan or one of
these lettermans or one of these and
he's like oh my god i'm a beatles nut
paul mccartney holy [ __ ] here we go i
got to say hello i gotta say something
so he goes up to paul mccartney and he
kind of just starts freaking out he's
like uh paul i just i die and paul goes
take 15 seconds and then come back
and
it seems kind of douchey but it's like
you need 15 seconds and then
and he could he gives you 15. he could
just go all right you're done but he
gives you 15 seconds he knows how big he
is exactly and then they then they i've
heard he's cool paul mccartney oh he
seems like a great guy [ __ ] genius
it's the most obvious sentence ever but
but yeah and he's still alive he's the
only one still going that's not true
that's ringo's
what about anne banks
ringo died from ovarian cancer as well
[Laughter]
yeah uh when i met when i did the first
gig with seinfeld
you know freaking out beacon theater i'm
in the green room with him i get there
way too early i don't want to be late
i'm just sitting there he comes in takes
the blazer off hey what's up and it's me
and his like one man or one uh what do
you call right-hand man and kevin great
guy and he knows i'm freaking out so
he's like just relax he's a normal guy
i'm like i know i know and he comes in
and you're like i'll be fine and when he
comes in
it all hits you like oh my god i'm at
the beach and i'm opening for jerry i
watched it when i was a kid with my
parents and he goes how are you and i go
and i did one of those and he goes all
right how are you and i had a mental
mental moment where i go hey this is it
get it together i had like a pep talk
with myself in the moment wow and said
like
talk to this [ __ ] don't freak
out don't geek out
this is it you're here quit bitching
quit quit queefing and i i snapped into
focus and then i was better wow but i
had to do that because it was it was too
intense it's seinfeld yeah i know it
makes sense didn't he request to share a
green room
yeah cause he wants the hang he likes
comics
whereas a jlo would be like i would
never want to hang out with the opener
which is cool
cool about jerry
damn that's crazy yeah no it makes sense
so that you just kind of
lose it for a second i lost it he's
jerry he's jerry yeah i lost it i had to
mentally grab my [ __ ] and go hey
[ __ ] focus and i i did and it went
okay you said it out loud jerry's like
what did you call
yeah dude you know uh you do those late
night sets and then you just like you do
a set and it's kind of like a you know
you're like what the [ __ ] just happened
and then you're on the couch
and you're just chatting with like conan
or colbert
or [ __ ] jimmy fallon or whoever
according whoever it is kimmel whatever
show you're doing and you're just kind
of like
oh wow this is weird yeah because we're
just so used to the clubs and doing the
work that we're not used to the
celebrity [ __ ] we're not totally
totally you know but then with a guy
like conan i really did you know he's
one of my heroes you know for so like
ever since i was a little kid my brother
always watched conan and so my brother
watching it made me think it was like
cool my brother loving conan
uh made me be like oh [ __ ] i look up to
my brother my brother looks up to conan
then you start watching conan you start
staying up you start kind of showing up
to school with not enough sleep and
you're like yeah but i want to see in
the year 2000 you know that sketch you
want to see all the dumb sketches
because you know you love yeah you're
just sitting there with him and you're
like whoa i'm just talking to conan and
now you got a guy doing that to you we
got a guy i may have the show i know
it's not conan but it's uh
they watched uh
they watch i uh what if i got this i got
this they watched the rooftop they
watched they watched uh out to lunch
they watched mark's new netflix special
30 minutes he hasn't plugged in this
[ __ ] podcast
he's forgetting [ __ ] let's do it for the
drinking mark's new netflix half hour i
think you should have an hour personally
but uh he's got a half and it's i
haven't seen it yet because we're
pre-recording these but i know it's
[ __ ] killer it's out right now on
netflix get the date right now exactly
what's out right now yeah she showed up
so where are you i was there i can't
wait to see it man i'm so excited it
should be fun and i again it was a
pandemic half hour where i put a lot of
[ __ ] together and made it all work with
gub and tape but it went well and it's
dark as [ __ ] and i can't believe i got
away with half of it i love it there's a
lot of cosby says too
that's uh yeah man also hey man beacon
theater may 7th i hope you show off so
mark said seinfeld beacon that's to me
it's a dream come true as a new york
city kid so i hope you guys buy tickets
to see me at the beacon theater in new
york city may 7th tickets at
samurail.com
shows milestone i mean that's an epic
netflix is a milestone man because you
[ __ ] know you mean you did it the
right way i mean you you i still think
i'm like part of me is angry because i'm
like you should have an hour you're a
great stand-up
i know we all know that we all know the
game is rigged and it's stupid but i
will say i slowed down with that drink
there
[Laughter]
but uh no you're you're a [ __ ] beast
you've been a beast and i've known you
and uh
i mean [ __ ] out to lunch but i'm like
i'm also thinking like uh still got it
you know yeah yeah i'm thinking mark's
first album ellie had madison comedy on
state yes you know i'm thinking of jokes
that are like yeah sure but i mean mark
we've watched each other from the from
the get-go so it's [ __ ] cool it's
cool to see cool
well the beacon is the beacon is butts
and seats netflix is like some some dude
you could do the beacon dude i don't
think so you could do the [ __ ] if i
could do what you could do new york you
could do it if i could do it i'll do it
in a couple of years
i'm just saying enjoy the beacon look at
us this is like a pulpit let's see
there's two guys who can't feel good
exactly
in the words of uh
harvey keitel
let's not start sucking each other's
dick just yet
is that it is that the line yes all
right i've been drinking but uh yeah all
right either way we gotta run i mean
she's gotta go to get an abortion we're
going long here come on i mean which
week did this come out january what matt
peters 16. oh jesus so you know this we
passed the capitol right richmond
the anniversary
richmond michigan
timonium maryland uh
hartford connecticut sacramento columbus
i probably added an la date by now in a
san diego or houston date by now just go
on my website who the [ __ ] knows
everything takes forever no one pays you
what you're worth so you have to hold
out you're here uh but yeah a lot of
good dates coming mark what do you got
ah man i'm all over the road kansas city
sacramento punch punchline la jolla
comedy store
uh
[ __ ] didn't see that mark i can't see it
i got to get more dates up there look at
that
um bridgeport connecticut at the
dinosaur barbecue yeah that's all that
[ __ ] city has they tell you about it
non-stop it's sad we got dinosaur
barbecue my cool do you have a noose
yeah it's still on the tree actually out
there
um
yeah [ __ ] i can't uh think of my day i
gotta update my website i got dates that
are six years old on there
uh but yeah go to marknormancomedy.com
i'll update it by the time this is out
we'll have a whole bunch of new stuff on
there uh i think i'm doing uh carbs at
one point doing chicago cobs is as good
as it gets baby you got you got to go to
soda mori or swan oyster depot while
you're there best seafood in the game is
that where he went with schumer
we went to sotomayor with schumer i went
there with vitor too oh amy bought out
the whole [ __ ] place remember that oh
that was big big money that was all that
was a big dick move yeah that was badass
that was great clusterfest there was a
theo vaughn it was a nicki glazer we had
a good crew rachel rachel the guy from
drunk history was there who [ __ ]
snubbed you i know i know
he wasn't ready to see me he was like oh
hey you're here i'm like i'm here i must
have said something so horrible on that
show that it just
couldn't be couldn't be here it's called
drunk history what do they want i know i
got drunk you were drunk your history
my career is history all right thanks a
lot she's gonna give me emails that we
might be drunk at gmail.com rex peeves
uh jokes drinks whatever the [ __ ] you
want subscribe to the patreon it's
growing you guys you guys are showing up
we love it here here we love you keep
drinking
uh on instagram jamie samantha lynn
j-a-i-m-e like jaime like the jewish way
and on twitter just jamie samantha
you can catch me at shows i always share
dates and i have broadway comedy club
january 15.
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you